very soon after the selective service
act is passed then you get the espionage
act um which of course is back in the
news um in 2022 what's the espionage act
the espionage act is a sort of omnibus
bill it contains about 10 or different
provisions very few of which have to do
with espionage but one key provision
basically makes it illegal to say or do
anything that would interfere with
military recruitment
right
and that that provision is used to shut
down
radical publications to shut down german
language publications
and you know this is really has a
chilling impact on speech during the war
could you put into words what it means
to be an american citizen
that is in part sparked by world war one
so what is what is that
what does that mean somebody that's
should be willing to sacrifice
certain freedoms to fight for their
country
um
somebody that's
willing to fight
to spread freedom elsewhere in the world
spread the american ideals like what
what
um does that begin to tell the story
what it means to be an american
uh i think what we see is a change right
so citizenship during world war one now
includes um uh the obligation to defend
the country right to serve right and to
if asked to die for it right
um and we certainly see that and i think
we see
the the close linkage of military
service and u.s citizenship coming out
of this time period
but
you know when you start making lots of
demands on people to fulfill obligations
in turn they're going to start demanding
rights
and we start to see not necessarily
during the war but after
more demands for free speech protections
more demands for for equality for
marginalized groups um and so you know
obligations and rights are sort of
developing in a dynamic relationship oh
it's almost like
an overreach of power sparked
a sense like oh crap we can't trust
centralized power
to abuse like to drag us into a war we
need we need to be able to so there's a
the birth of that tension between the
government and the people
it's a rebirth of it you know of course
that you know that tension is always
there but but uh in its modern form i
think it comes from this
reintensification of it yeah so what
about uh you said that world war one
gave birth to the surveillance state in
the u.s can you explain
yeah so the espionage act um you know
sort of empowers
federal organizations to watch other
americans they are particularly
interested in anyone who is obstructing
the draft anyone who is trying to kind
of
organize labor or strikes or radical
movements
and anyone who might have sympathy for
for germany which basically means you
know all german americans come under
surveillance
initially you know this is very small
scale
but
but soon every government agency gets
involved from the treasury department
secret service to the post office which
is sort of reading mail to the justice
department which mobilizes 200 000
volunteers yeah and you know it's it's a
really significant enterprise much of it
goes away after the war but of all the
things that go away this core of the
surveillance state is the thing that
persists
most most fully
is this also
a place where government the size of
government starts to grow in these
different organizations or maybe create
some momentum for growth of government
oh it's uh it's it's exponential growth
right that um you know that over the
course of the war
by almost any metric you use right the
the size of the federal budget the
number of federal employees the number
of soldiers in the standing army all of
those things skyrocket during the war
they go down after the war but they
never go down to what they were before
and probably gave a momentum for growth
over time yes absolutely
you